GUSTAVO FRANCO: First, before
we jump into the topic,
so who am I?
I'm Gustavo Franco, aka Stratus.
I've been with Google
for roughly 11 years now.
I work on the Customer
Reliability Engineering
team, which is part of the
SRE organization, which
is partially responsible
for this launch
if you're watching here, if
you're not watching at home.
Let's go over some assumptions
before we jump right into,
like do you have an SRE team,
how to get to an SRE team.
I have a couple
assumptions, and you
can correct me if I'm wrong.
I think, hopefully, most
of you here are already
familiar with what SRE is.
And you probably at least
have a vague understanding
of the difference
between SRE and DevOps.
If you don't, follow
that link in there
to get more
information about what
we think of the difference
between SRE and DevOps.
The long story
short here, and we
had a presentation
earlier at this conference
from Seth Vargo, one of the
Developer Relations folks,
about the difference
between SRE and DevOps,
which I recommend you to watch
if you haven't watched it yet.
The gist of it is we say SRE
is an implementation of DevOps.
A lot more information for
you if you follow that link.
And the third assumption
that I have is there's
some leadership buy-in.
VPs, C-level executives
have some buy-in.
Either if you're a
manager or if you're
an individual contributor,
try to implement,
adopt SRE best practices,
and implement an SRE
team at your company.
People generally agree with it.
So why are we here?
So first, this can be seen as
a guided tour of the Google SRE
workbook.
If you haven't read it
yet, we have a copy online.
I'll have a link at the end.
We also have some
copies for you.
So after this talk,
towards the end,
you can actually get a copy
from us as part of this talk.
But first things first.
We're here because
I'm going to guide you
through some chapters of the
workbook in order to get there,
in order to get to
your first SRE team.
The second reason
why we're here is
I'll give you concrete examples.
One thing that we
get feedback often
about when we talk about SRE
with customers like yourselves,
is, OK, I understand
the practice.
I heard about SLIs and SLOs.
How do I really do it?
How do I get from quote,
unquote "nothing,"
or an operational
team or a developer
team that wants to adopt
SRE to actual concrete,
tangible action?
So we're going to
cover some examples,
some concrete examples there.
Last but not least, we're
here so we can use this
as some kind of benchmark.
So if you have
SRE teams already,
you can kind of
compare notes with us.
We'd like to hear your feedback
right after the presentation
through questions, or
just we can go in the back
and have a
conversation about it.
Cool.
So first things first.
I will go through with
you just getting started.
So you're sitting here, and
you don't have an SRE team yet,
and you're really interested
in adopting SRE best practices,
and you have an SRE team.
We're going to go through that.
I'll also cover different
SRE implementations,
so different flavors of SRE.
And I'll also guide you
through common SRE practices
by level of maturity.
This is totally arbitrary.
I made this up, right?
If you say--
I go through advanced
and you're like,
no, my team is doing
half of advanced
and half of beginner,
where am I at?
I don't have an answer for you.
I just have rough
guidelines in terms
of what I see beginner
teams at Google
doing after intermediate
teams and advanced teams.
And then, of course,
what we should do next.
So if you're just
getting started,
first recommendation
is establish
service-level objectives, right?
So I won't get into
details of what
this means, but,
of course, you can
see the link to the
chapter of the book
as I mentioned before as
you access the presentation.
You can get a free
copy of the book,
or you can go to google.com/SRE
to read a chapter.
One thing I will say
about establishing SLOs
and why that's so
important if you're getting
started, even if you don't
have an SRE team yet,
is how is it that
you're going to justify
prioritizing stability
over feature velocity
if you don't know where your
bar for reliability is at?
Your bar has to be
anything over than 100%.
My colleague Jesus
was just explaining
the proofs presentation,
so hopefully some of you
caught that.
Second thing that we
recommend folks to do
is adopt blameless postmortems.
It's very easy in
some companies.
It's very easy in some companies
for people to buy into that.
In some other companies,
people are like, no.
If someone makes
a honest mistake,
I still think we should quote,
unquote "punish" them somehow.
If you are one of
those companies,
if you're working in
one of those companies
where people want to
quote, unquote punish folks
because they make
honest mistakes,
it's really hard to adopt
blameless postmortems.
So if you cannot
change that culture,
maybe SRE is not for you,
is not for your company.
Maybe it's not
going to help you.
It's not going to work.
So back to you one
thing to consider.
Establish SLIs and SLOs.
Establish blameless postmortems.
Establishing
blameless postmortems
is all about culture.
It's not technical.
And if the company
culture is not ready,
you're going to have a
problem adopting your SRE best
practices, basically.
The third one is, once you
have blameless postmortems,
establish a process to
manage production incidents.
Why a process?
Well, you don't want people
to be paged at 3:00 AM.
You don't want people being
paged in all the weekends,
and they don't know what
to do with that pager.
So if you have SLIs, SLOs, you
have blameless postmortems,
document your process
to respond to pages.
We will often see SRE
teams, SRE functions,
where people have adopted SLIs,
SLOs, they write postmortem.
They have the practice
of writing postmortems.
When people get paged,
they don't know what to do.
So train your folks.
Establish a process.
And back to this chapter
covers more details
of things to do there.
All right.
We covered things that if
you're just getting started.
So three things.
But I understand not every
SRE team is created equal.
Maybe you're able to
do two out of three,
and it might be OK,
except for maybe blameless
postmortems because you
might have cultural issues
at your company.
Let's talk about why not every
SRE team is created equal.
I see commonly five to
six SRE different flavors,
different team
implementations, and that's
where people get quote,
unquote "a little lost."
Because they say, oh,
I do SRE, but I don't
have SRE quite like Google.
And I say, well,
how do you do SRE?
And after they tell
me how they do SRE.
And I say, no, yeah, we
have several teams at Google
that are just like yours.
It's just Google has an
entire SRE organization.
We have very different
implementations of SRE
inside of Google.
So I'll guide you
through some of the ones
that I've seen both at
Google and outside of Google.
The first one is I think
is interesting to highlight
is consulting.
So consulting is--
you may have a couple
SREs that are consulting with
developers on their design.
They might be consulting
on configuration changes.
on the instant response,
on blameless postmortems,
on defining SLIs and SLOs.
But at the end of
the day, consultants
don't tend to get
quote, unquote,
their "hands dirty"
with changing
configuration, changing code.
That's why they're
called consultants.
This is OK.
If this is all you
can afford, if that's
what you want to
implement in your company,
you can have an SRE team.
Your first SRE team
can be of consultants.
We'll talk about some
of the main risks
I've seen in consultant
teams in a moment.
Second implementation--
embedded teams.
So embedded teams, you have--
generally, you don't
embed an entire team.
You embed individuals of a team.
So you may have a team
of five folks, five SREs.
One, two, three
are embedded with--
each, right?
One or two each are embedded
with different developers
working with them, right?
We also have those at Google.
So if you have this at your
company and you're saying,
I'm not doing SRE
quite like Google,
yes, you are, and it's OK.
So that's one implementation.
It's totally acceptable.
That could be your first team.
You could have one, two
folks to be embedded there.
Generally, the difference
between embedded and consulting
is we don't see--
we do see embedded folks
going hands-on, changing code
and config.
They may or may not be
on call with the team.
But back to it's
your implementation.
You define it.
You define the details.
The third and the fourth one--
they kind of bundle together
because they tend
to be similar--
are the tools or
the infra SRE team.
So the tools or the infra SRE
team is this SRE team that
specializes on either
a set of tools,
so they build tooling for the
developers, for the company--
reliability tools, maybe
monitor-related tools,
maybe the SLI/SLO-related
tools, instant response,
blameless postmortem tools.
Or they could be an
infrastructure SRE team,
where they're responsible for--
let's say now you're
running on GKE,
or you have your own
Kubernetes cluster.
So that infrastructure
SRE team may
be responsible for the quote,
unquote "infrastructure,"
not the application.
Slice is when you get a
slice of your problem space
at the company.
It could be a product, right?
A single product is
a slice, or a set
of products, a product area.
So those are SRE
teams that they are
responsible for a
slice of the problem.
Kitchen sink, or
everything, tends
to be the most
common that I see in
other companies, where in the--
especially when they're at the
beginning of the SRE journey,
that's their first SRE team.
So they tend to name the
team after the company.
So if you're a company and you
name your SRE team Company SRE,
and I ask, what is this
SRE team responsible for?
You say everything.
That's what I would consider
to be a kitchen sink
implementation.
I'll leave it up there
a little bit because I
see a couple folks taking
photos of the implementations.
We'll cover main
risks and a little bit
about on-call and team size,
which people ask me quite a bit
about.
Before we get into that, one way
to scale-- people ask me often,
OK, what is the
right implementation?
What is the right mix?
It depends.
One thing that I've
seen folks scaling, some
of these implementations
in place,
especially tools in for
a slice and kitchen sink,
is tiers of service.
What does that mean?
You might tell your
developers, hey, you know what?
I cannot be on call.
I cannot do project work
on everything that we have
in the company.
And even though I'm responsible
for a slice or tools or infra,
it's too much.
We have too many tools.
We have too much
infrastructure, or we
have-- the slice is too big.
So I've seen people
adding tiers of service.
So you can imagine
a first tier where
you say, I'm just
going to do consulting,
a second tier, where you
do project work, and then
eventually, a third tier,
where you do on-call.
Those tiers are
defined per company,
so you can write down, as
part of your team charter
or a separate documentation,
where you get agreement
you have with the developers
what the tiers mean
and which service is
going to be in each tier.
It's a way to help you to scale.
So it kind of goes to-- you're
going from zero to one team,
but you might be like, oh,
I feel like I need five SRE
teams all at once.
You may not need
to go from 0 to 5.
Consider implementing
tiers of services.
So people ask me about
team size and on-call.
I'll just go through
this quickly.
The gist of it is Google
has recommendations
in the books about minimal
on-call size, et cetera.
In reality, companies
tend to be a lot smaller,
especially in the beginning
when they're adopting SRE,
so we cannot really give
you a hard-and-fast rule,
like here are the minimal for
every single implementation
of SREs you should have.
Consulting and embedded?
You can start with
one SRE if you like.
If that person is not
going to be on call,
and there are no concerns
of burning that person out
on call, you're totally fine.
But if you have to
have 24/7 on-call,
we do, at Google,
recommend every team that
follows this set to have
a sister team, so six
plus six at minimum,
or a total 12.
So that's on the books.
But back to it depends, right?
It's a company thing.
So I don't have a
set formula for you.
Let's go over main risks of
each implementation, which
I think can help you
if you're at zero team
and you want to get
to your first team.
So hopefully, that will help
you to decide what should
be your first implementation.
So for consulting, the more
consultants that you have,
if you don't have anything
else, it may be perceived as--
the team maybe
perceived as hands-off.
Because you're telling
folks what to do,
you're not doing it, right?
So in the long run, the
more you have consultants,
it's really hard to
scale their impact.
They cannot really go
deep on the problem space.
People are going to
be like, oh, yeah,
the SRE consultants are
great, but we cannot have 50,
100 consultants and keep adding
consultants indefinitely,
depending on your company space.
Back to if you have
a team of consultants
and it's working well
for your company,
you're measuring success however
you measure success internally,
that's also fine.
I'm just listing the
risks that I've seen based
on my personal experience.
Embedded may-- the individuals
in an embedded team
may suffer from lack
of knowledge sharing.
Let me tell you what that means.
Several colleagues of my--
colleagues of mine in different
companies, they tell me--
because they have several
embedded teams--
one common struggle
is they send one SRE--
they have a team of 10 people.
They send one SRE to 10
different developer teams,
and it's really hard to get
those individual SREs back
into a meeting room to
share their experience.
So that's a risk.
If you're not doing that, then
eventually those individual
SREs that are
embedded on the teams,
they feel more like such
a part of a developer team
they're embedded with that
they struggle to come back
and have this SRE
identity, which
tends to be a problem because
they're not sharing their SRE
experience with each other.
So some things to
watch out for if you
adopt an embedded strategy.
For tools or infrastructure,
the only risk I've seen
is the scope might be too narrow
for what the company needs,
right?
If your company has
several applications
and you only have one
SRE team and their folks
are doing tools
and infrastructure,
it may be too narrow for them.
For slice, it's similar to
tools, but one thing that--
it may be obvious-- is if
you keep adding slice teams,
it's really hard to scale just
by adding extra slice teams,
SRE teams, to your company.
And last but not
least, kitchen sink
works really well in
the beginning, right?
You have a team and their
scope is basically unbounded
and it's everything.
They can help out
with everything.
As the company grows, as
the problem space grows,
that team's impact
and their ability
to understand things
deeply diminishes.
So you see the deep
impact going from deep
to very shallow impact.
And why is that?
Well, because there's just
too much work to do, right?
So if the scope is unbounded,
one thing that we see
is people start with
the kitchen sink,
and then they eventually staff
consultants or embedded teams,
or they actually start slicing
their kitchen sink into two,
so they have two slices.
Cool.
So now let's go back
from implementations
to common practice for most
implementations, right?
I'll give you more concrete
examples based on maturity,
and common practices I've seen
SRE teams adopting, and links
to the book so then
you can kind of--
as you're browsing the SRE
workbook at google.com/SRE,
or one of the copies
that we have in the back,
it'll make more sense for you
to do what I'm talking about.
So beginner teams-- so
first thing's first, right?
Staffing plan
should be in place.
So how is it you're
going to fund this team?
How many people do you need?
So we talk about
this in the book.
The team may or may
not be on call, right?
So keep that in mind.
You may have an implementation
that does not require on-call.
On-call is something that
we say SRE does, may do.
But several SREs are
not necessarily on call.
So you don't need to
have your SREs on call
to say I have an SRE team.
That's not a requirement.
We also generally
see beginner teams
to start putting a release
process and canary rollback
where it's applicable, right?
So we understand
mobile applications,
you may struggle
to have a canary,
but you have a process to which
you may have a service side
feature control.
But generally
speaking, SREs tend
to start being
concerned about release
process in that beginner stage.
A playbook or a [INAUDIBLE]
book, like the most common term
is in place.
And you do some kind of
disaster recovery task.
So we also see, often,
beginner teams doing some kind
of disaster recovery testing.
It can be theoretical
in the beginning.
You may not have software to
do any kind of quote, unquote
"chaos generating activity."
And SREs may be
doing, at that point,
some kind of independent project
work in the beginner phase
that may or may not be visible
by the developer counterparts.
So this is important, right?
In the very beginning,
SREs may be doing work
to automate toil that
the developers may
be even unaware of.
My recommendation for
you is back to you
got leadership buy-in, right?
Remember the assumptions at
the beginning of the talk.
Well, if you're just having
impact the developers cannot
see, that your C-level
executives or your VPs cannot
see, you may be doing great,
but this is bad, right?
So you want to have some
kind of, eventually, project
work that is going to be seen.
The impact can be
measured, right?
So in the beginner
phase, it's OK.
You might be automating
toil for yourself.
But I would also recommend you
to look into your first team.
Are they doing the work
that possibly impacts
the business that can
be measured and be
seen by the rest of
the organization?
Healthy SRE teams, regardless if
you're in the beginner stages,
if you're just
really implementing
SRE best practices at the top,
they have enough on-call load,
meaning if you are
on-call, there are pages,
but you're not on-call overload.
We have a ton of
guidance in the book
of what we think is
on-call overload at Google.
What we think of what is
on-call overload at Google
may be different
at your company.
People might be more comfortable
with more pages, more alerts.
People might be
comfortable with a lot less
than we have at Google.
You need to define that, right?
You need to measure
that yourselves.
And another super
important thing
that should actually be
the title of this talk
that I see in healthy SRE
teams is a team charter.
So let me talk a little
bit about team charters.
It's the constitution,
the definition
of the scope of the team.
Back to the kitchen
sink SRE team,
if you just start an SRE
team and you don't have that
document-- you're not
writing down your scope--
your scope is unbounded.
Your scope is
everything, and we hate
that in software engineering.
So why would we, as
SREs, accept, oh, sure,
anything the company needs, in
terms of work that may or may
not be related to
SRE, we will do?
Define your boundaries.
Define your scope.
Sure, your boundaries may move
as the business needs move.
But you probably want
to write this down.
And it's better for everyone
to understand you're planning,
to understand your work, to
understand your implementation,
right?
Is it kitchen sink, is it slice?
And so on and so forth.
And that gets me to you then--
if you have a charter,
the discussions
leading to writing
down a team charter
gets you to have some kind
of SRE and have alignment.
And that's when you're going
to see the misalignment, right?
Things that you disagree
with your developer
leadership, or your
C-level executives,
or the priorities for production
and what the SLOs should look
like.
If people really buy
into not aiming for that
unachievable 100% of uptime.
And Joint planning
execution is also something
that we see in healthy teams.
So back to if your
developers, your executives,
bought into yeah, we cannot
achieve 100% of uptime.
The team charter for
the SRE team is great,
and they are doing joint project
work with the developers.
So all of a sudden,
yeah, SRE can
be a successful
implementation of DevOps.
Let's go to intermediate
SRE teams, right?
So I covered it
in the beginning,
and I covered a little bit about
what I see in health SRE teams,
regardless if they're in
the beginner stages or not.
Well, the SLO that
you set at the top
is going to be reviewed
and changed, right?
Generally, I recommend
every six months or so.
But then again, whatever
works for your company.
If you need a rule of
thumb, every six months,
review your SLOs.
The business priorities
might have changed.
Your customers might be
more strict or less strict.
So you want to review that
with your business owners.
Review your metrics,
your objectives.
We also see in the
intermediate teams,
they start being able
to measure that they
have some low volume of toil.
By toil, meaning the work
that could be automated,
or some operational
work that you don't want
to automate at all.
There are different definitions
of toil, I know, out there.
It's a contentious issue.
But the way you define
toil, we tend to say, well,
half of the time for
an SRE team should
be spent on software
engineering-related or system
engineering-related
project work, right?
Well, the other half
or less is then toil.
Can you measure that?
So intermediate SRE
teams tend to start being
able to even measure that.
We don't see that as much
at the beginner stages.
The last point here
is you start reviewing
incidents and the action
items of those incidents.
Because you establish
blameless postmortem practices
at the beginning.
So now you start being able to
look at-- you have the time.
You have the quote, unquote
"slack" for project work,
for software engineering,
for systems engineering work.
You're not drowning in toil or
in operational work anymore.
Well, what is it that you
can do with the extra time?
Well, one of the
things you can do
with the extra
time is let's pause
and evaluate the action items
that we have for incidents,
and see if you prioritize
the right things to mitigate
duplicate incidents.
And at the end of the
day, SLO violations
start to have consequences.
So what does that mean?
It doesn't necessarily
mean a freeze,
even though we recommend
a freeze often.
By freeze, meaning stop
launching new features
if you completely exhaust your
SLO and invest in reliability.
Several business that I work
with, they say, we can't.
We can't afford to do that.
What else can we do?
Well, can you at least
dedicate more resources
to improve reliability?
If you cannot stop,
completely halt,
your pushes for new features,
for new launches because you
have contracts, you
have commitments,
can you at least invest some of
the developers' time to improve
reliability?
Because at the end of
the day, if the product
is completely down or
is not meeting the SLOs,
the customers are leaving you.
So SLO violations
have consequences.
So that's one thing that is
common for intermediate SRE
teams.
The consequences, you have to
define it within your company.
We do recommend pause
future launches,
but I know it doesn't
always happen.
Some kind of capacity
planning is in place, right?
So if you're in the cloud,
if you're using Google Cloud,
you understand
your quotas, you're
working with your account team,
and you understand organic
versus inorganic growth.
You may or may not
have some software.
SREs may have delegated
that to another team.
But we see, often, SREs
being concerned about that.
Some kind of capacity
planning is in place,
and it could be purely quota
planning for Google Cloud.
Last but not least for
intermediate SRE teams,
I also see a lot of
strategic planning.
So people start
writing road maps,
thinking about not just the
next Scrum cycle, if you're
on Scrum, or Agile,
or the next quarter.
People are talking
about, what is it
that we want to achieve by the
end of the year as an SRE team?
Let's switch quickly to,
then, advanced SRE teams.
Major positive business impact.
At least one person,
two SREs that
can claim that
because of their work,
there is some major
positive business impact.
Back to if your SLIs are
attuned with business metrics
and SREs are working
to maintain or improve
the business reliability,
well, it checks out, right?
SREs should be able to claim
some major positive impact
on the business.
Scalable project
work, meaning SREs,
if, in the intermediate
and beginner phases,
they are trying to tackle one
service at a time, one problem
space at a time,
they switch to now--
or some parts of your team start
to switch to horizontal impact,
meaning they don't work
just on one service with one
team at a time.
They're starting to come up
with solutions that positively
impact several services,
several teams, several developer
partners at once.
SLO-burn-based
alerting is in place.
This one here, I
would love to have
that back in the beginners'
place, but I'm being realistic,
right?
Ideally, you would have that
for-- like every beginner SRE
team that I see,
they have some kind
of alerting that is SLO-based.
I would be lying to you
if I said that's where
I think the SRE practice is at.
I think that's one that we
should move to the beginning,
and we're not there yet.
But if you can help me,
please, please, please
work on SLO-burn-based alerting.
And why is that?
Because if you go look at your
alerts right now and you get
alerted, there's probably
some impact to the system,
but do you know if your
customers are unhappy?
And are you measuring for how
much time they're unhappy?
And back to linking to
Jesus's presentation,
my colleague before,
about SLOs, right?
You need to tune them.
So if you don't have a
SLO-burn-based alerting,
which kind of
alerting do you have?
And are you happy
with your alerting?
And are your customers
happy if you're alerting?
Is it tuned with the
customer experience?
The last one one is some kind
of automated disaster recovery
testing.
So then we see folks talking
about chaos engineering
quite a bit, right?
So it's something that I see
more in advanced SRE teams,
where they understand
what is it that I
can do that is theoretical
disaster recovery
testing, or fault injection?
And they understand
what is it that they're
going to do in their
own production systems
and what is it they're
going to do in production.
And eventually, they have
some kind of automated system
to stress test their SLO.
Cool.
So now we're at the
point in the presentation
that people might be wondering,
what should I do next?
What do I do from here?
So first things first.
Read the SRE workbook.
We'll open for Q&A shortly,
but if you're leaving,
please get a copy
of the workbook.
It's by the door now.
And read about CRE.
Read about my team.
I have a link to the slides.
The slides will be available
after the presentation.
You can just google
Google CRE, and there's
a whole blog post explaining
in details what we do.
And contact your account
manager if you're
interested in having
some version of this talk
and also more
information about SLOs
and instant response from
customer reliability engineers
like myself, so SREs working
with you with the customers.
So contact your account
manager about that.
And right now, you can just
ask questions if you have any.
[MUSIC PLAYING]